Billy the footstep ball of the floor
good pass over to Dante Cunningham for
the easy three Spurs continue to shoot
lights out 313 Alex lamb
I'll pick of the draft look you switch a
big man out on tray young and that's not
gonna work the second chance deflected
pass Trey's got to the head
[Applause]
the San Antonio Spurs look at three
young how about that lead they're
shooting he said the shots are finding
us but on this curve shooting those
three-pointers is that we got to be in a
better position
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
he did our
get control of it join Prince
step back corner three
[Applause]
makin it happen Bazemore T zip up and
with Gasol and his face takes the heart
fall
but not the worst for where it appears
boy he was up there court now he's
picking it back up at the fourth quarter
way again he's has that rhythm you know
he feels that he's hot he's confident
and they're finding him he's delivering
I mean just a tough shot this is good
defense here by rudy Gay good challenge
but Tory and princess
tracheas from the G at Georgia Tech
[Applause]
the depth on this thing
that one was from the parking lot
it goes through the net at 2.2